[Music]
you know for most of the history of
human civilization before tv before
movies before media before the internet
every country or society would produce
only a very few famous people
you had to achieve something or be
someone of incredible significance to
earn fame so the famous were all kings
and conquerors and explorers and all
that sort of thing each generation would
have maybe a famous artist or two maybe
a writer a philosopher an inventor an
innovator so fame was a very rare
commodity
and famous people belong to an extremely
small and exclusive club for everybody
else on earth fame was basically
unattainable and i imagine that most
people didn't spend a lot of time trying
to think of ways to attain it because
the average person was known only by the
people that they knew
and the idea of being known by lots of
people you don't know which we might
call the definition of fame would
probably not have seemed terribly
desirable to the average person during
this time
but
um then tvs came along in hollywood and
the media
and the ranks of the famous swelled
considerably suddenly you didn't have to
do anything significant to achieve fame
you just had to be good at pretending to
do significant things
that glowing box in the living room gave
you a window through which you could
peer voyeuristically and the people on
the other side of that screen were all
famous because although they knew they
were being watched they didn't know most
of the people who were watching them
this made fame a little bit more
attainable um and and yet still only a
relative handful would ever attain it
but it did make fame much more desirable
even for those who had never attained it
because the non-famous were spending so
much of their lives watching the famous
and envying the fake lives they lived
inside that box
and then the internet came along
and social media close behind it
fast forward a generation and now a
measure of fame can be had by anybody
with a twitter or tick tock or instagram
account
we're all famous now to one degree or
another
we are all known by people who we do not
know
we present ourselves as objects to be
viewed and we hope envied
some portion of people will experience a
greater amount of this kind of fame
but nobody is required to achieve
anything or be anyone or do anything or
have any skill whatsoever to be famous
anymore you don't have to be a conqueror
or king you don't even have to be a
decent actor you just have to offer
yourself up as a spectacle
and others have to take you up on your
offer even if it's never quite clear why
they find your offer appealing
this is just one of the one of the
myriad reasons why kids should be kept
off of kept off of social media because
although they might deeply desire to
make their lives into a spectacle for
public consumption
that desire is not healthy
and we should do everything we can to
prevent them from fulfilling it for as
long as we can
because there are a lot of downsides to
fame
but those downsides used to be balanced
by the fact that at least the famous
people were all by definition talented
and accomplished
modern society however provides the
opportunity to experience the downside
of fame without any of the upside
a lot of mediocre people become famous
for no good reason and then are promptly
consumed by this fame that they never
earned or had any business experiencing
it's kind of the equivalent of lottery
winners who are destroyed by their
wealth must much more quickly and more
consistently
than people who earn their fortune
through skill and hard work
paraphrasing jeff goldblum in jurassic
park the lottery winner has wealth but
it didn't require any discipline to
attain it
and the same could be said for fame on
the internet we're all sort of
attentional lottery winners
we all get much more public attention
than we really want and it didn't
require any discipline to attain that
attention
and that after a long preamble
brings us to the subject of our daily
cancellation
if you feel like you are getting the
respect you deserve in life well i've
got a solution for you established
titles is your opportunity to earn the
title of lord or lady and gain the
respect you deserve all you need is a
one square foot plot of land in scotland
and your title pack you'll receive at
least one square foot of dedicated land
on a private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land these title packs
are a fantastic gift and the best way to
surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends boyfriends or even family
you could even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc
establish titles as having a great
extended new year's sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established titles
dot com matt walsh or just click the
link below
as the daily wired reports quote the
ex-cop father of a 14 year old american
girl who has over 1 million followers as
a tick tock star shot and killed an 18
year old boy who stalked his daughter
and had traveled hundreds of miles to
her home where he fired a shot through
the family's front door
the father was not charged under
florida's stand your ground law ava
madri 14 whose videos show her singing
dancing or pulling pranks
noticed in early 2020 that one of her
followers eric rohan justin 18 of
ellicott city america maryland
was becoming obsessed with her messaging
her in snapchat and instagram and even
joining online games that she played
with her brothers according to new york
times ava initially responded to justin
as she did with other fans but learned
that he was buying her personal
information including her cell phone
number from her friends in new jersey in
florida and then he would call and text
her with the number
okay now to be clear we're not canceling
ava because she's only 14 certainly
can't be blamed for any of this we also
aren't canceling eric rohan justin
because he's dead anyway and it would be
kind of redundant his cancellation has
already been handled it would seem
instead we're canceling ava's parents
now her dad should be commended for
shooting the predator but that's really
where the commendation ends
aside from that one bright spot
her parents have played a pretty dark
role in this story as we'll see
continuing
it says ava's parents allowed her to
sell mr justin a couple of selfies that
she had already posted to snapchat the
times noted continuing after that mr
justin messaged ava on venmo with a
breakdown of what he would pay for uh
booty pics and photos of her feet quote
unquote stuff that a 14 year old
shouldn't be sending she said
she blocked him on all her accounts in
venmo uh messages viewed by the times mr
justin pleaded with her to unblock him
mr mr madrid the father said he texted
mr justin's cell phone told him that ava
was a minor and demanded that he stop
contacting her
now you've hopefully already noticed a
number of red flags where the parents
are concerned
starting with the very fact that ava is
a 14 year old tick tock star
there's no such thing as a 14 year old
tic toc star with good parents
but we haven't even gotten to the
biggest red flag of all yet back to the
article it says
since the incident michael mourino an
entertainment lawyer created agm
creations for ava she is now represented
by washington lawyer lonnie davis and
his public relations firm
ava is still on social media and her
parents support the idea
her mother claimed that she did not want
ava to be forced off by sick individuals
saying why should we allow them to stop
her maybe she's meant to bring awareness
to all this
ava said that at night she has doubts
about continuing on social media but by
the morning's quote i thought of all the
benefits most people would say the money
and yeah it's a huge benefit but it's
the experience i got to go to la the
people that i met just being able to
make other people smile is what i like
the enjoyment of seeing the impact i
make on people's lives i post a video at
night close my eyes in the morning it's
exciting to see how much how many views
i get
rob madgery echoed quote it's like
christmas every day because then you see
it build i think we just had to allow
her to make a decision and sort of
support her i think it's going to help
her heal it sounds corny but i don't
know what else you could do for it
okay sure dad your adolescent daughter
has been traumatized by the experience
of a gun-toting psychopathic tic-tock
fan blowing her front door open with a
shotgun and the way to help her heal is
to allow her to make more tick-tock
videos
now let's back up and review the whole
scene for a second
a 13 year old girl
wants to open a tick tock account
her parents allow it
she begins amassing a huge army of male
followers who all enjoy watching her
dance
her parents continue to support it
an adult male stalker takes a very
special interest in the girl and her
parents her parents allow her to sell
pictures of herself to this person
then that same individual shows up at
the house with a shotgun
the dad dispatches him his one good act
in the whole story and immediately
allows his daughter to get back on
tick-tock and continue building her
brand
now with a lawyer and a pr firm behind
her
now ava says that she you know she wants
to continue because the good outweighs
the bad
what's the bad
well for one violent stalker is trying
to murder her that's that's one bad
thing
what's the good um well she likes seeing
how many views she gets on her videos
there would seem to be something very
wrong with ava's scale and i know what's
wrong with it she's 14. no 14 year old
can appropriately weigh the good against
the bad and consistently make reasonable
decisions based on that calculation
i couldn't at that age
that's why the child needs her parents
to view the situation from a vantage
point that is inaccessible to her
they're supposed to be bigger and not
just physically able to see farther down
the road
but all these parents can see it would
seem are dollar signs
and that makes them especially gross and
negligent but compared to other parents
who let their young children pursue
social media fame they're worse only by
degree not by kind
though today we're focused just on them
and to them we must say you are both
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated